The Joe Rogan experience.
I'm very excited to talk to you because I had a guy on, uh,
Jamie Metsley yesterday,
a scientist who scared the outta me talking about China.
Who's talking about China. We were talking about China, massing, Naval power.
Oh, China's taking over tech companies and how,
how huge they're getting and how much influence they have over their people,
as opposed to the way we.
Do it. Well, he's not wrong. He's not, yeah. I can't spot the lion in what,
what you just said, but, uh, I mean, look, I mean, there's so much we, we can,
we can talk about, but
if you think about it just in the past handful of months, <affirmative>,
um, there was this solar wins hack right by the Russians.
So the Russians go in, they hack into a company called solar wins.
That is an it management software company that happens to be, um,
fairly deep into government organizations, agencies, treasury, and,
and a variety of others throughout the us government.
A and they're also into parts of the Intel community defense
department, uh, in a lot of commercial sectors. So anyway,
the Russians figure this out now round about December or January,
um, Microsoft, you know, identified this as a problem. And,
and I think it was the head of Microsoft said,
it looks like the most sophisticated attack we've ever seen.
So this is December, January timeframe.
And they're still trying to figure out the depth of this hack by Russians at the
same time and going back months and months,
and months and months before the Chinese had been engaged in a more
sophisticated attack that while everyone is focus down,
what's going on. And so fully aware that we got problems right from,
from nation states out there who don't like us,
everybody's talking about solo wins. And now it's, you know,
they've just now released information about the Chinese attack against, uh,
Microsoft exchange servers, uh, running the exchange email systems.
And this is, uh, enormous. And so the Chinese,
yeah. I mean, we've been so focused for four years on the Russians, you know,
and they're, you know, they they're out there to cause us all sorts of problems.
So we should be focused on 'em, but, but it's China, that's the biggest problem.
And so this guy is absolutely right. Jamie's right.
It was terrifying. Yeah. What to, what he,
he was talking about the way he was explaining how they, you know,
they have this plan with, I think he said 20, 49 to be the,
the global superpower of the world. Mm-hmm <affirmative> and essentially be,
take the place of what America used to be.
Yeah. They do it their way and do it their way,
which means we're gonna bypass all the costs and the heavy lift of research,
your development over the years in which you gonna steal everything. Yeah.
And they've been doing it for decades. So people think, oh, China,
it's a problem. It's a problem. We've talked about this before. You know,
this idea that perhaps this is just something relatively new or it's popped up
during the previous administration of Trump and honest God's truth is it's been
going on for decades.
And they decided that that's how they're going to get to the top of the food
chain is by stealing,
because it's a lot easier to Hoover up everything and then reverse engineer it.
Uh, and the technology has made it even easier, right? It used to be old school,
they'd go out and recruit somebody.
They'd find some Chinese American working for a company here in the states,
they'd appeal to sort of, you know, you gotta help the motherland and,
and they would, and that was the old school way of doing it.
But in a cyber theft is it's,
it's incredible what they're able to do and this latest attack while they
they're still trying to sort out the mess. Right. So when.
They do this, so if they get into this, you email server,
do they, are they targeting anything specific? Is there specific companies,
are they just like throwing a net out there and seeing what they catch?
Yes. Is the answer to, um,
both of those it's it looks like what happened here was that,
um, their, their initial point of attack or their initial focus was,
uh, intelligence. Right? So then it branched out and it branched out very,
very quickly, right. To hit everything, small companies, medium size companies.
And that's kind of the Mo for the, the Chinese, the Chinese regime, right?
The, uh, and the, their Intel, uh,
they've got this long vision and they've also got the resources and they've got
the desire to Hoover up everything and then sort it out later, we take a, as,
as, as a country, we take a very sort of targeted approach, right? We say, okay,
this is a piece of information. That's a priority tasking for the us,
for our national security.
We're gonna go out with gonna figure out who has access to it.
We're gonna develop a very sort of surgical strike to figure out how do we get
to somebody who's got this piece of information. That's typically how, uh, we,
or some of our allies would operate the Russians.
The Chinese have always had a different approach. I mean,
the Russians is less elegant.
The Russians are just throw at the wall and see what sticks. Right.
But the Chinese they've got this long view and they've also got this ability and
they'll, so in this particular attack that they're still trying to assess, um,
that was perpetrated by, you know, um,
Chinese state sponsored hackers based in China. Uh,
they, uh, they're just gonna take everything.
And then they'll S they'll figure out what they got. A lot of,
it's gonna be just, you know, cha not, not of interest,
but they're gonna find a lot of gold in there too.
And they're willing to do that because they've got the patience to do it.
They'll, they'll develop a target, they'll develop a,
a potential recruit for years and years and years, or they'll,
they'll infiltrate, um, a society or an organization. Right.
I they'll put a student out here.
Who's actually working for the PLA for their Intel operations.
And they'll put 'em out as an undergrad,
and then they'll go to school and they'll get good grades and they'll go to a
grad school and they'll get a job and they'll get another job.
And then 30 years down the line, it may pay off,
but they're willing to make that investment. So, so we.
Should be scared.
Well, <laugh>, we shouldn't be scared, but we should. Yeah. Uh, we, I,
I don't think we should be scared, but I think what we should be is,
is pragmatic and understand why, uh, for, I mean, there was a lot of,
you know, human cry over the past four years. I can't believe I just said,
hu cry. I don't even know what that means. I it's old timey,
is it golly? <laugh> what look at cry. It's like the cats pajamas.
Um, it's uh, so, you know,
four years of Trump and sort of as antagonistic relationship with China,
people were all ringing their hands in Washington, DC, you know, sort of the,
the think tankers and the traditional pundits and the diplomats of, of, of, uh,
of, of, uh, the us, you know, the long term people, oh my God,
we've got this average adversarial relationship with China. Well, you know what,
we better, right. So that's not a bad thing.
So I'm hoping the current administration maintains to some degree and we'll see
what happens.
They still haven't responded to the solar winds to the Russian attack. Right.
They're talking about it now, they're saying they're gonna,
they're gonna engage in several clandestine, uh, retaliatory acts.
Well,
it's not that clandestine because they've announced that they're gonna do it.
Um, and so, you know, but,
but I'm hoping that they will take serious action against the solo winds,
Russian act, but they've got to with China,
they they've got to maintain this posture. We've got to, uh,
make it clear and understood to the Chinese regime that we're not gonna put up
with this. They're gonna keep doing it, but we gotta make it painful for them.
So how do.
You make it painful?
Well, you know, it's the all word sanctions.
You gotta go with the sanctions because there's not much else trade wars.
You know, I know everybody hates a trade war, not everybody, but, um, you've,
you, you've, you've gotta find a way because the problem with, with cyber, um,
shenanigans is that there's no real clear definition, right? We know if we, if,
if a country fires a ballistic missile off, uh, uh, you know,
we know what the rhetorical or retaliatory act is.
We know what appropriate response is in cyberspace.
When you're talking about warfare,
coming up with a definition is very difficult and hasn't been done yet.
We've got cyber command, right.
And we're still trying to sort out what are appropriate responses because it can
escalate quickly. Right. Next thing, you know,
they get shut down on our infrastructure. Right.
Well,
that's what I wanted to talk to you about supposedly what they did in India.
Mm-hmm <affirmative>. So if, if you could explain that to people, they,
they shut down the power grid in India, allegedly. They said they didn't do it,
but apparently there was some sort of a warning about the power going out,
right? Yeah.
Um, they've done it. Um, I mean, the Russians hit it famously in the Ukraine,
right? I mean, not that long ago. And, um,
China's ability to interfere, uh, in, uh,
infrastructure here in the us or in India or, uh,
with our allies is because for years now they've been probing.
There's been testing going on. You know, there, we, we, we talk about, um,
that's a good example. We talk about how, um, in the us,
we have three grids and I think people were,
were stunned to find out that Texas has its own power grid. <laugh> well, yeah.
Uh, but it's not so much people were like, oh my God, look at Texas.
They're terrible. Know they wanted to make it a political thing. Right.
They wanted to make it sound like the,
the reason why it's so terrible is because it's Republicans and they've got,
they want their own independence. Well, no, all three grids are, right?
The east and the west and the, and,
and the Texas grids are all cobbled together over the years.
So it's a very sort, it's like a, a patchwork quilt.
And they were never built to withstand, uh,
physical attacks. I mean, you could drive by any substation, right.
You could get close enough to pee on it. And there's, they, they,
they certainly were never designed to, to withstand a cyber attack. So
over the years, what goes on is essentially a mapping, right?
Where, whether it's the Russians, whether it's the Chinese,
whether it's the north Koreans using Chinese capabilities,
whether it's the Iranians, whomever they're in there,
probing and trying to understand the weaknesses, and they're drawing up a map.
Now, the reason why they're doing that is to have a game plan. Right.
And I guarantee you sitting on the desk somewhere, not to are from, you know,
G's office is a playbook that says, if this thing escalates,
here's what we're going to do. And if you think like it was bad in Texas,
you know, a couple weeks ago when you know, the power was out and it was bad.
But think about that lasting for 8, 10,
12 weeks around the right power grids, shut down. What happens?
You can't transport. Right? You can't get cash fuel. Doesn't get to,
to the gas stations, food, doesn't get to the stores. Uh there's you know,
depending on the time of year heat issues, obviously water supplies, uh,
and that's where the next big battle's gonna be fought. Right.
They're gonna bring it to the Homeland and we will do the, the same thing.
Right. It's not like we're not doing it. Cause people always say,
when I say something like that, well, the us does it too. I think, well. Yeah,
the us does it. We better, we better hope we're, we're, we're, we're.
Prepared that does that frustra you frustrate you when people say that. Well.
The us does it too. Yeah, it does. In a sense because,
and this is where I think, um, you know,
that now personal opinion comes into it. Look, I spent most of my,
my adult life overseas,
and I like to think that I've got a fairly pragmatic view on things.
I do admit that I, you know, obviously look, I,
I look at the us and I like to think, and I have seen on occasions, we,
we do a lot of things for, for the right reasons.
Sometimes we don't do it properly. Right. We, we make mistakes.
Of course we make mistakes. Uh, but we try to self, correct.
I guarantee you, if we're talking about the major powers out there,
if we're talking about China and us, if we're talking the Chinese regime,
I'm talking about, obviously if we're talking about the Russians, the Iranians,
the north Koreans, we better hope that we stay up there. Right. And are able to,
um, exert influence and leverage and control the top. Right.
Because if it's, if it's <laugh> I, and again, I maybe I'm wrong here,
but the Chinese don't view anything in an altruistic manner, the Chinese regime.
Right. It's all about self-interest.
And sometimes I'll tell you what's frustrating.
Sometimes is we seem to be the only country out there that apologizes right.
For that sort of thing. And so when we act in our own best interest and we go,
well, we're really sorry about that. You know,
we're kind of acting in our BU best interest. Well,
every other nation does it and they don't give a.
Yeah. But shouldn't, we be the moral high ground for the world.
I think we should. I think it's nice if we do all the same they do. We say,
sorry.
Yes. As long as we do all the same, I guess it doesn't cost anything to say,
sorry, it's not a bad thing. It's.
Like, it's not a bad thing.
We're setting a tone. Yeah. I guess that's true. As long as we're,
as long as we're also then at the same time acting at our own best,
it just because we have to be, again, we have to be pragmatic.
If we think that somehow, you know, look at climate change,
that's obviously it's back on the table. It's, it's a big issue,
a major policy direction. Hey fine. Great. Who doesn't want clean energy,
but you know, to, to, to act as if China's not the, to, you know,
the, the number one polluter out there is insane.
Yeah. That's, that's what gets weird, right?
Yeah. It does get, it gets a.
Little weird, giant difference between the amount of particulates,
the amount of pollution, the amount of CO2, you know? Um, I think they've,
they've tried hard to mitigate that over the last few years in particular.
But do you remember when they had the Beijing Olympics? Yes.
And they had to shut everything down because the air quality was so bad. Yeah.
That the athletes, you know, would,
it would actually be dangerous for the athletes to, to perform and to compete,
catch new episodes that Joe Rogan experience for free, only on Spotify,
watch back catalog JRE videos on Spotify, including clips,
easily seamlessly switch between video and audio experience
on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data cost. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.